walk him to this video dreadmaster Ricky
gets rickets rickets with that from
France Maxine Lagarde came some Bishop
g5 is an interesting line against
against the French and he played age six
and i'm not i'm not so familiar with the
the theory this is why i played them
Bishop f4 I know one Bishop h4 sg5 with
them with interesting play okay so his
son plan involves going if I've of
course and I wanted to go Queenie 24 but
now realized that this is nonsense of
course he's got a fall all the time
yeah this is uncomfortable a bit
queena 5 is not really a threat queena 5
you can play d5 so it's not it's not
serious but I want to go on a square
where control we form a half maybe he
thought it was a threatened to erecting
reacted to it not really a it wasn't
really necessary to do so okay let's um
try to get a knight to e5 and okay maybe
this isn't so bad night to see five if
this would be very nice 95 okay he's got
five
hmm
castling long yeah you should do that
anyway probably oh this is a playable
position for white I have quite decent
control here maybe I get Luke h1 Luke
age 16 okay so he's not really not
really worried at the moment but I take
age 6 yeah at least them here and
understand why isn't okay what am I
taking a fall and man it's not it's not
clear to meet this position maybe a form
that's the problem this is a bad night
I need to activate this piece badly if
this would be an act of peace everything
would be okay I think
I'd love to play a 4 maybe i should i
should actually know the d7 bishop
saying so if he takes i can recapture
and because of the bishop they cannot
take III maybe after taking on a 3 i can
even take with the knight Knight takes
Queen III King be one still this
happiness hanging I have some activity
now I don't know okay but after taking I
can always take with the pawn this is
not bad at all okay now this I didn't
expect thought but I don't need to take
it I can just I can just drop back this
closed position as it's nice for me
anyway i can i can take a fall whenever
I want
it's completely closed on the King side
yeah it's really completely closed I'm
really wondering what is what he's doing
I mean I'm just winning on the queenside
and turn he's some completely relaxed
about closing up the Kings side
I just play be fine and push the pause
there's simply nothing in terms of
counter play going on
so I just just take them or something
better yeah it's it's it's it's enough
check
in this kind of position he also has
absolutely no idea to enter on the
queenside it's completely covered
everything's covered so on I can I can
just play here um the only thing but I
need to be cautious about is some wait
wait wait 97 I need to do this first is
after Queen trade the idea of bishop age
for suddenly okay yeah I take I take
this chance here to enter with the night
trying and getting getting anateck him
check
my king is still still safe at least I
don't don't see anything
check
hmm ah he's having Carroll to play with
Bishop f2 what deck and I have my
flights at ways to to play the system
yeah what the heck check unbelievably
check check yeah time morning shine
where to place for wind check check
check this is really frustrating check I
mean how bad did you play that I mean
like atrociously bed check check check
check that didn't carry punish it I did
it first but no check check check check
check check check I know not resided to
offer draw white 48 ha what deck what a
game my god ah what a frustrating game I
mean a half you wouldn't like with every
kind of move you can win and I don't
manage to do it ah I mean I'm I'm
speechless really speechless what the
heck did i do there I know this is
winning no doubt about that but mmm why
am I even allowing that I mean I can I
can do anything just just play let's say
this one and what is he doing plus five
I mean now
yeah I'm sorry to be a not much fun here
it happen I'm just frustrated because it
was just as so straightforward and he
played I'm sorry so many bad strategical
moves that you can it was just
unbelievable closing up the King side I
mean you're busted on the queenside and
you just close it up like I mean it's
just an automatic win and it's every
every school kid can do that is white
but I'm not every schoolkid I'm just an
idiot a 96 was winning the Queen I
didn't even pay attention to that just
playing a playing routine moves
unbelievable unbelievable ok I hope you
enjoyed it in some way